okay so hi i'm albans f from JPMorgan
and I'm very glad to be here and even
more glad that my parents didn't come
over because that would have been
embarrassing okay so let's let's start
we JPMorgan have a very large project
related to Python and I think it's very
interesting because it's unique it's
different when I came over I didn't
imagine that something where this
structure exists so let's let's share a
little bit about it so JP Morgan this is
the agenda not going to go over it
so JP Morgan has more than two thousand
to two hundred thousand employees I
think it's already two hundred and
seventy and yes more than 440 thousand
developers I mean program is not people
who are actually technical they know
what they're doing they're not sitting
next to the desk pretending to do
something with the computer and we
process a huge amount of payments every
day we do risk analysis we do a lot of
kinds of data processing and trading we
have offices around the globe so there's
always someone awake and working so we
need to be ready for that for a project
that can live 24/7 or be updated 24/7 so
Athena this is the project I work on its
pricing risk management and trade
management platform I think it's the
biggest software running in Wall Street
it has thousands of servers and also
thousands of developers most of it is
Python and it's built for rapid
development
it puts really the developers as a real
part of the business it's not only a
trading business today in the FinTech
world
time to market matters and developers do
sometimes make the change between
different organization technology is
important just to give you some other
numbers it's probably the largest Python
code base in the world I think that more
than 25 million lines of code and it has
a very fast push to production mechanism
someone can update production in about a
matter of minutes so during the trade
someone can do something it's not
something that you ship to production
and hope it will reach the like in a
month and I think it has an average of
800 changes per day 800 times we go on
change production and I think it's
pretty impressive so let's discuss
continuous delivery there's a lot of
noise first a developer he writes code
there's some kind of a review process
and then we go into version revision
control something is being built
of course you test what you do till here
it's continuous integration if you go
all the way push the production that's
continuous delivery so you need the
thing the change to get into production
and then deploy it so then this is push
to production continuous delivery let's
discuss this a little bit so the most
important thing in this kind of model is
time to market you want to be fast you
want to get there you want to push the
changes fast it drives the user
satisfaction up because if I get a call
or a developer receives a call and he
says well I don't like this label on the
button if I don't have it well I'll tell
him yes it's a five minute task I'll
just find the code that'll make the
change I'll push it in but we go to
production only in two months well he
won't be so happy but I've done my thing
it took five minutes and also I will
have to remember what happened and if I
may
we spelled something wrong then it will
take me or maybe another developer will
receive the task and it will take me a
long time to get back to it and get into
the context so my productivity will be
much better and also but this all
process usually if I have a program that
ships of production once every six
months so everybody knows I have one
month of regression testing so people
will be really sure that this is table
because people clicked on all the
buttons for a month and they're really
sure that is okay but if there'll be a
change and someone missed something I
would be able to fix it that fast
because my process isn't made to be
pushed to production or to fix
production that fast I'm used to really
long release cycles and all this in
order to provide hundreds of changes to
production every day you have to rely on
information because we want to change a
hundred times a day production but we
don't want to break it hundred times a
day we want our customers to be happy we
want this to be useful and there's a lot
of money in the trade if we do something
really wrong we might lose money we
might be down this has a like a big
price if facebook will be down for a few
minutes then they will lose a lot of
money coming from advertisements but we
might lose our customers money and we
will lose a lot of credibility this is a
really high price and also continuous
delivery is tricky with distributed
systems but yes always deployments are
tricky with distributed systems but this
is something you sometimes need to take
into account so let's discuss monolithic
code base that is a thing the thing you
don't know till now most of what I said
was pretty much familiar so when a
little code base it means
all the code is in one global repo one
very big very large repo 20 something
million lines of code it's a trunk based
development
it means head of trunk is what goes to
production we don't have a few heads we
actually have one head that matters we
we like small frequent changes we do
have some support for branches and
feature toggles is a good practice
sometimes you can ship something with a
flag that says it's off or maybe you'll
turn it on during runtime in order on
some demo hosts so let's discuss this we
believe that transparency brings quality
a little bit like open source if you
have the shame factor if you share your
code on open source you will care how it
looks like that people can understand it
so 100 mil of ethical days that's a real
important part of it and it also enables
collaboration less duplicate efforts for
some utility class everybody sometimes
in his career use some or develop some
age XML parser like that's I think 20%
of the developers in the world what they
do is they develop XML parsers or JSON
parsers yes this requires a big
investment in tooling it's not the
standard methodology and it's hard and
it's a challenge to keep the hygiene of
the codebase you need to rule and be
very strong to enforce some behaviors
not any code standard is ok we want some
standardization and a single revision of
a code makes life easier you don't
really care for the exact revision that
was two months ago what's in production
what's the head of trunk is what matters
how does this apply to Python like we
didn't talk about Python yet and I'm
halfway through so Python is special in
a way that you don't need to compile
everything when you change one file or
one model and it's on your file system
you are running the latest you don't
need C++ Java linkage and long processes
you actually run against what you have
so we focus our main constraints on code
review and tests as build won't break
like there's there's no build so no way
it's gonna break we have a lot of
integration tests which fit the monolith
code base model because let's discuss
the other option micro-services when
you're a micro service all you know is
your small service and your integration
test of what you think the world looks
like
but that's your mock it's a really small
thing if you have the whole world the
whole context then you can test against
the world and the world or the other
development team will update his
processes and then your integration
tests could be up to date I think this
is one of the most unique things we
usually use Python and we load it from
our file system but what if we load it
from somewhere else we can load it from
we load it actually from a key value
storage imagine Redis let's say you had
Redis and when the key is the path and
the value is the actual code the Python
code so and there are other key value
storage ins but it's actually behaving a
little bit like distributed file system
whenever you will update the Python file
you will say it goes to production then
it will be there the process will start
and it will use the latest and greatest
so actually deployment solved
you can reach production in no time
technically and you don't have to
package it all in one big zip you can
have parallel processes of development
so even if we go a hundred times of
production today it's not that
developers are waiting for each other
they can run in parallel so continuous
delivering you saw the previews slide
but with Python it's it's easier we can
do this we don't need to build we don't
need package we got ourself to trivial
steps it's much faster than what it
would become in a long compiling
building language so how does it look
like a bit more code and technical so if
I have some key with a value then I'll
run Lib bar and well yeah I run the
hello thing and I'll get the print the
wonderful PI data print but when I run
against the database I have another
option let's say I don't like the print
and yesterday I had awesome print
everything works I was happy so I can
launch the Python launcher with my
timestamp and say well I want to run
this as yesterday and I can do that in
most systems you can't run production as
yesterday you can maybe in SVN take the
code as yesterday in gate I think you
can eat you can't even do that due to
the branching process sometimes you have
to and you can't choose the current one
from yesterday so I think it's very
special and it enables a lot of things
so just consider someone taking the
timestamps when all the regression tests
passed and running with that regression
test past timestamp and knowing that
everything was checked and delivered and
a bit more details so we discussed about
fast updating production but someone
would have to test himself because I
write typos all the
I wouldn't like to put my typos straight
into production someone giving me a
phone call complaining that it doesn't
work for him so I want to test myself so
when I run against production so let's
imagine we have some kind of a main in a
so a will import B we report C will
import D everything is trivial a little
bit like file system but over here I
have a different model of layering I can
open a very large number of developer
layers areas where I can open B put it
in my area and change it this is the
actually change I want to push the
production so I'll test it or run it
locally when I'll do always develop a
layer I a will import B and B will
import C and I'll get something like
like this this will be my effective
runtime environment and it can even go
and oh I always think about it a little
bit like a cache miss so I always go
from the top to the bottom if I find
something I take it if not then I go to
the big production database which has
everything there are no merges in
runtime so I take the file that I have
here and but there are no we bases no
updates no pools what's in production is
in production
it's my change and I'm lazy loading it I
don't have all of my computer so when a
developer comes to his first day at work
people tell him ok use you have their
clients or this and that
what's needs to be installed and you can
use all the code it's working
it's very complex to get something
working like that for a new developer on
a very large and scaled environment and
I think this is being done very
effectively sometimes in some cases
there are groups and teams need some
more collaboration they want a staging
area they want to share their code
before it goes into production so yes
you can work on
one staging area but sometimes it's not
enough so you can add more layers so in
this case add my developer layers on top
of the shed staging and what will be run
is always the thing on top so someone
altered the main on a and a will import
B B will import C and C will import B
for production so production code user
developer area
this is developer area staging area and
production code all in one computer like
in one pre effective query so
conclusions continuous delivery is
possible at any scale especially scale
of a codebase there are ways which are
not microservices I'm not saying micro
services are bad or wrong but there are
different approaches automation and fast
feedback is important and critical to
make better products and to enable push
to production as time to matter is time
to bark it matters for us matters a lot
and things are much easier Python know
build things can be updated individually
and can be loaded from key value storage
and well it's not free but it was worth
for us it is an imported system for us
so a few references there is a reference
from Google and I think there's also
some reference from Facebook some we're
dealing with monolithic code dates and
the code dates that all the company can
access and yes we in Israel are growing
our Center Tech Center and we are hiring
so thank you very much and if someone
has a question I'll be glad to answer do
you have some time Lesage
okay so questions if yes
they have different kinds of skills or
the pathology or it varies and depends
on the line of business there are
different lines of business with
different org charts so I can't like the
a few different organizations dealing
with this system it's a bit of an
implementation detail but I'll give you
some hint we have some kind of a layer
between the developer and production
where you push from so you put it there
and then you review so you know what's
the next upcoming change you don't have
a conflict on that in which case we do
not recommend like a large analytical
phase
it depends what you're looking for it
depends on language so it wouldn't be
relevant in C++ so if you want C++
something that works on bare metal maybe
it will be the way but for this case you
can add some binaries to the process
that will be under the hood and get
performance and change the logic the
more top layers very rapidly for which
cases I wouldn't select that it varies
because oh if you want to create less
people to depend on you if you're
worried of a lot of people depending on
each other so they're not but it enables
you to enforce some really small things
for something not to be too important or
to know all the small environment you
care about then don't care about the
world some cases it does make sense
[Applause]